- What I realized, as I've
become more part of the right
and conservative, and I do
things with Turning Point or,
just within the
last couple of weeks
I hosted this PragerU Gala,
where DeSantis was speaking.
It was at the height of
the don't say gay thing,
and I'm bringing him on stage.
I introduce him to my husband.
He immediately says,
congratulations on the kids,
big smile, picture with us.
It's like that
shows the difference
between community
and collective.
(rhythmic music)
- Hello everybody, and
welcome to "The Rubin Report".
I am not Dave Rubin.
I have sort of quaffed
and sprayed hair.
I am wearing a tailored blazer.
But I am not Dave Rubin,
I am Michael Knowles.
My guest on today's episode
of "The Rubin Report"
is Dave Rubin.
Dave Rubin, a "New York
Times" bestselling author
and the author of the new book,
"Don't Burn This Country".
Dave, thank you so much
for coming on your show.
- Michael, thank you so much
for having me on my show.
And before I say anything else,
does it hurt that you
have to refer to me as
"New York Times"
bestselling author,
because they did not
put you on the list.
Now your book sold like 10 times
what technically should've
put you on the list,
but they felt they
could stick it to you.
For some reason they
didn't stick it to me.
Maybe they're gonna stick
it to me with this one.
- Yeah.
- But how does that feel to you?
I mean, we all know that
"The New York Times"
is complete nonsense
and bunk and propaganda
and everything else,
but nonetheless,
as someone hosting
someone else's show
and having to say that.
- I am very much a non "New
York Times" bestselling author.
And for a while,
we were all joking,
and you would say you wear
this as a badge of pride,
because "The New York Times",
we all know they're bunk.
"The New York Times"
bestseller list,
like all the rest
of their newspaper,
is an editorial product.
There was actually a
court decision about this.
So they really can just
pull you off the list,
no matter how many
copies you sell.
So that's one side of it.
But on the other side,
and this actually gets to what
you talk about in the book.
It does matter, the fact
that the radical left
controls all of
these institutions
will determine where
your book gets placed
in the bookstores.
It will determine if it
goes on classroom curricula.
It will determine how it's
talked about, how it's reviewed.
It really matters, and
we're now just talking about
one small subset of just
one institution on the left.
This is true of all of the
left-wing institutions.
So there's a lot I wanna
talk about in your book,
but first, because
I'm hosting the show,
this is my show today
thank you very much,
I wanna talk about my
favorite part of the book,
which actually comes
in the middle and it's,
in the book, it's a sort
of natural follow up
to "Don't Burn This
Book", your first book,
and it talks about
all sorts of ideas
and different parts
of philosophy,
libertarian philosophy,
conservative philosophy.
But what I love
is in the middle,
you don't just talk about ideas.
You talk about doing something.
You talk about, not just how
we're gonna tweak this policy,
how we're gonna tweak this.
You actually built
something, you yourself,
you Dave Rubin, built
something called Locals.
Locals, now affiliated
with Rumble,
which is a separate
conservative,
or at least non-woke
institution.
- Yeah, non-woke institution.
That's really all it is.
I wouldn't say it's
conservative or libertarian,
or progressive or Democrat or
Republican or anything else.
We basically just wanted
to be a neutral platform.
And you know, for all the
years, you know Knowles,
you and I have been
having these chats
on each other's
shows, regardless of
who's hosting what,
for a couple of years now.
And even before I knew you,
I was having all of these
talks with all of these people.
And we were talking
about free speech
and we're being censored
on these platforms
and we know about de-boosting
and shadow banning,
and all of these
other Orwellian terms,
but nobody's doing
anything about it.
And it really
started hitting me.
It was like, man, the
cavalry ain't coming.
There's nobody
coming to save us.
We have to save ourselves.
And you know, it's
kind of funny now.
Four years after
having created Locals,
and since we've
merged with Rumble,
and my idea with Locals
of course was hey,
I just need a digital home.
I need a place where I own
my video, I own my audio.
I own the user data, so that
if I ever wanna leave Locals,
not that I would wanna
leave, I created it.
And by the way, I
think only one creator
out of our tens of
thousands has ever left.
And it had nothing
to do with Locals.
But I thought, let
me create this thing
and then see if other
people want it too.
So we really created it for
me first and then we realized,
oh wow, we've actually
got a business here.
So this is pretty great.
Because otherwise just
talking about the stuff,
and this is an ironic
position, I suppose,
for two guys that
talk for a living,
at some point it starts
making you crazy, right?
If you and I just complain about
the Republicans didn't do this,
and the Democrats did do this,
and wokeism in schools,
and gender theory, and,
but we don't actually start
building new institutions,
at the end of the day,
we're gonna go nuts.
And by the way, that's why
a lot of the talking heads
that you see over the years,
they get progressively crazier.
Because if you're just
screaming about stuff,
but not changing stuff,
you're going to be crazy.
And since you are
hosting my show,
I will say something nice about
the fine folks at
"The Daily Wire".
Look, you guys are doing
the same freaking thing.
What you guys did with
Jeremy's Razors, as an attack,
instead of just taking,
instead of just being attacked,
you said no, we
will attack Harry's.
They make up this nonsense,
it had to do with your tweet.
You guys poured, I think,
millions of dollars
into an incredible campaign.
You're now selling
your own razors.
You're launching a
$100 million campaign
for Daily Wire Kids.
That's very much in line
with the ideas of the book.
Politicians are not
here to save us.
You either better figure
out a way to save yourself,
or you better find some people
who can help you save
yourself together.
Not as a collective, but
really as a community.
Not as just oh, I'm a cog
in a machine, but as oh,
I have shared values
with these people.
Let's build some things.
That's why I created Locals.
That's why we
merged with Rumble.
That's why we do stuff together.
And that's what people
are looking for.
They're not looking for
us to just bicker over
marginal tax rates, or even
the more existential stuff.
They're not just watching us
to have the endless
debate about abortion,
which of course we can
do and we've done before.
They want answers.
That's what I'm interested in.
Otherwise, Knowles, we're
gonna, don't you feel that?
Like we would just.
- Yeah.
- Don't you feel it, if
you just do this every day,
you just talk about
this stuff every day,
but you don't do anything,
what's gonna stop
you from just being
a complete talking
head, screaming lunatic.
And there's plenty of those.
They're all on MSNBC.
- That's right.
This is something that's really
refreshing about the book,
but more importantly,
it's refreshing about what
is happening right now.
What you're doing with Locals,
what we've done with Jeremy's
Razors and now DW Kids.
We're not gonna take our
kids to Disney World,
we're gonna take them
to Wire World, whenever.
I shouldn't even say that,
'cause you know
Jeremy's gonna go dump
$50 million into that the
minute he even hears the idea.
There is this
issue on the right,
and we're all guilty of it.
On the left you can take a
room of a hundred leftists,
maybe they have
different interests
and different points of view.
You can get them on
board with something.
You can get them
to work in concert.
I mean, that's what we're seeing
with the woke corporations
and the big tech platforms,
and the government,
and the media, and the schools.
They all get on the same page,
no matter what their slight
disagreements might be.
When you get into a room full
of right-wingers, you get,
if it's a hundred right-wingers
you're gonna get a hundred
different opinions,
and they're gonna fight tooth
and nail over every issue.
And a lot of those
debates really do matter.
A lot of those debates
are really important,
but they paralyze you.
They stop you from
doing anything.
And so I'm just so
happy to see, okay,
while we're figuring out
whether it's marginal tax rates
or it's life and death,
while we're doing that,
how about we build
up some institutions
that will even permit us
to have that discussion?
- Well, you know,
the thing is Michael,
you know the joke,
it's like, if you go to
a libertarian conference,
in essence you're just
gonna have 15 opinions,
you're gonna have 10 people
at the table, 15 opinions,
on whether you should have
driver licenses or not,
and then no one ever
accomplishes anything, right?
But there's a reason,
there's a fundamental
reason that does happen
with people on the right,
and it doesn't happen
with people on the left.
And it gets to sort of
what I just hinted at,
the difference between the
collective and a community.
They love the collective
that, you know,
we're just pieces of
the machine, all of us.
And we're just completely
interchangeable.
And actually whether you're
black or gay or lesbian
or blind or whatever else,
that matters more than
whatever remaining
individual thought you have.
Now on the right,
what you wanna do is
if you believe in
the individual first,
that you, Michael Knowles,
believe it or not,
are capable of
logical, thoughtful,
- Sometimes.
- reasoned thinking.
- Occasionally.
- You have some sense of
how you can live your life,
and that the system
should just exist
to allow you to flourish.
And then hopefully
after you've figured out
some stuff for yourself, maybe
you meet a gal that you like
and you start having kids,
and then maybe you'll
move to a community
that some of the people there
are somewhat in line with
what you believe.
And then you can flourish
and build businesses up.
That's the bottom up approach.
They like the other approach,
which is there's a machine,
now fit into the machine.
And I get why that's
attractive to young people.
That, in many ways, is
what we're fighting.
That's kind of what
the book is about.
We're fighting something
that is much bigger than us,
because it's about
the human condition.
People just wanna fit in.
And if the last two years
of COVID taught us anything,
they will give up
almost everything
that is good and true,
in the name of fitting in.
That's what I wanna fight.
That's why the word
dystopia is in the subtitle,
because this is a dystopia now.
We are in a futuristic movie.
What happens in every
futuristic movie?
Big government
controlling speech.
People are afraid to
talk to each other.
People are locked
in their houses.
There's a pandemic.
Overreaching government.
It's like the
pieces are all here,
we just need Schwarzenegger
to come in and, you know,
defend the three boobed woman.
- Right, right!
That poor three boobed woman,
we've got to protect her.
Won't somebody please
think about the
three boobed woman.
- And remember,
they shoot her right up close.
Remember the guy just, yeah.
- Yeah, it's not,
you can look that up
after you finish this episode.
- Different,
different thing, yeah.
- Folks, it's different.
But I love this
distinction you draw here
between the collective
and the community,
because very often a
lot of talking points,
frankly on the right,
but just broadly,
posit that there is the
collective and the individual,
and they just leave it at that.
But of course,
if we're just a bunch
of atomized individuals,
then the minute that
we're all broken down
to the individual level,
the left is gonna come in
and bring us all together
and collectivize us.
Frankly, in the left's
collectivizing scheme,
you see this in
communist revolutions,
you've seen this for well
over a century in the left,
the first thing they do is
try to split people down,
break up their cultures,
break up their communities,
break up their families,
and then they can bunch
them all together.
And you're saying,
no, the individual
isn't the end of that.
There's actually, we're
human, we're social,
obviously we're
gonna come together.
But what we want is a
flourishing community
where we all fit, where
we all have a purpose,
where we don't lose
our individual selves.
Unlike what the
left is offering,
which is total homogeneity,
and do what we say or we'll
unperson you from society.
- Well, Knowles, I'm glad that
that part resonated with you,
because as someone that is,
and I still think of myself
as roughly new to this side
of the aisle, let's say,
and as you've long said,
I'm gonna end up the
furthest right of all of us.
That was an important
piece for me to take
from the first book, but
expand upon in this book.
In other words, the first book,
which was a defense of
classical liberalism,
really is a defense of
the individual first.
But that isn't enough.
That's one piece, and
that's an important piece,
and in some ways it's
the most important piece,
which is why I believe
it's the building block.
It's what all, as Jordan
Peterson would say,
it's what all Western
civilizations are predicated on.
That the individual
has sanctity and value
in and of itself, right.
But that really isn't enough,
and then this is
their great trick.
So their great trick is
okay, you're a person,
but really, as we said before,
you're just black or you're
just gay or whatever.
And it's like,
it's not just that we have
to say that's not true.
We have to show people
why that's not true.
So, for example,
look, as you know,
and you've been to my house
for dinner Michael Knowles,
I am married to a man.
Now that does not equal the
sum totality of who I am
or who David is,
or anything else,
just the way you and your wife,
your marriage or your
heterosexuality, is not,
that's not the
totality of you, right?
There's a couple other
things you got there.
You like cigars.
- I like to think of
myself as a super straight,
but I suppose there are other
aspects of my personality.
Sure.
- I love this phrase
super straight.
This came outta nowhere
because the left,
that's another
thing the left does.
Because they march
on everything sane,
now regular straight
people have to say
that they're super straight,
just to prove how
straight they are.
It's like, I'm the He-Man
of straight people.
But I mention this
because what I realized,
as I've become more a part of
the right and conservative,
and I do things with
Turning Point or,
just within the
last couple of weeks
I hosted this PragerU Gala
where DeSantis was speaking.
It was at the height of
the don't say gay thing,
and I'm bringing him on stage.
I introduce him to my husband.
He immediately says,
congratulations on the kids,
big smile, picture with us.
It's like that
shows the difference
between community
and collective.
Because if the right was
a bunch of collectivists,
what he in essence would want,
if you were to believe what
they tell you about DeSantis,
he would hate gay people, right?
He would be completely
against gay people.
And it wouldn't matter
if I agreed with him
on everything else.
If I did not accept and
bow to him at every level,
I would be out.
But what I have found
is I go to these events,
I go speak at
Liberty University,
the largest evangelical
school in the United States,
in front of 14,000 kids, and
they embrace you for that.
It doesn't mean we agree
on every little thing.
It doesn't mean that we're
gonna all love each other
and not judge in any way.
I mean, you know, from
a religious perspective,
I suppose you should
try not to judge,
but judgment is part of life.
We all judge, every
second of the day.
If someone shady looking
is walking down the street,
you judge them and
move the other way.
I mean.
- You racist!
You prejudiced!
Oh, sorry, I don't
wanna interrupt.
- No, you got it.
You got it.
But that's what they do.
Just to say that,
someone would imply,
well, what do you
mean they look shady.
You must be thinking about their
- How dare you!
- ethnicity.
And it's like, no, a shady
guy, if I saw some guy
with crazy facial things
and tattoos everywhere,
and holding a bat, I
don't know I might go
I gotta get on the other
side of the street.
But the point is, there is
a plurality on the right.
And I don't know, I
mean I guess maybe
this is what my next
book will be about.
Can it hold?
Can this alliance that
I'm trying to create,
that I think many of us
are trying to understand,
the more libertarian,
the ex libs,
the religious nationalists.
Can this thing hold?
I think it can,
if we just turn back to
those foundational documents.
But it ain't gonna be easy,
but I'll tell you this,
it's a hell of a lot better
than what those other
guys are offering.
- Right, and you do bring
up, this is a tricky issue,
I don't know that there
has been an answer yet
to this coalition.
Can you really fit?
Frankly, I don't know that
the conservative coalition,
even 50 years ago, made
all that much sense.
You've got the religious
right, traditionalists,
which are similar but not
exactly the same thing.
You've got the libertarians.
You've got sort of
war hawk Democrats.
They became kind of what the
neo conservative movement
of the last.
And you've got all these
isms and ists and that,
and they all came together
during the Cold War
to fight the Soviet Union.
The traditionalists hated
the, well the economic,
economic first, I
guess, led this thing.
But you had the libertarians
hated the collectivism.
Then second in the coalition,
you had the traditionalists
and the religious right.
They hated the atheism
and the iconoclasm
of the Soviet Union.
Then you had the
war hawk Democrats,
hated the Imperial ambitions.
And they all came together,
even though they didn't
agree on a whole lot.
Well now, I mean you're not
papering over differences here.
There are conservatives who
hold to the traditional
view of marriage, obviously.
Who are religious.
Who check all of these boxes.
Who simply will
not agree with you
on your more
libertarian positions.
And then the question is,
can everyone work together
to stop the woke threat,
without giving up their
own views in the meantime?
- So, as I said,
I don't know that I have
the answer to that fully.
Well, I know that I don't
have the answer to that.
You don't have the
answer, none of us do
because it's a work
in progress, right?
So we're not there yet, and
maybe there is no there there.
Maybe it's just a project that
will just continue sort of
as long as America
is to continue.
But what I would say is
generally speaking right now,
in 2022 America,
and this very much is
the purpose of the book,
we have to defeat
the woke thing.
And we have to give
the devil his due,
they've done a hell
of a lot of damage.
They have destroyed
so many things,
including imploding
Disney right now.
And I basically despise
"Star Wars" at this point,
because of what they
have done to it.
So they've destroyed our
educational institutions,
our financial institutions.
I mean, they've really
wrecked havoc over everything.
We should acknowledge that.
So, okay, there's that.
So it's that versus
the rest of us.
The groups that
you just decided.
Now I would argue, in essence,
we have to put aside
some of our differences
while we build the new stuff.
While we build the
new internet pipes.
While we build the new
businesses, Jeremy's Razors.
entertainment companies,
payment processors, the
whole freaking thing.
Now, if we can really
build some good things,
and of course they're
all gonna be built
in red states obviously,
the question is after that,
if we can get to that there
there, then what do we do?
How do we then, once we've
gotten to the promised land,
so to speak,
now the other issues are
gonna start popping up again.
Wait a minute, you
gay married people
and you Catholic
traditionalists,
we've got a problem here,
or whatever that is.
Now, we're gonna have
to work through that.
Again, I think the
founding documents
give us the best
path forward to that,
continuing to base it
on individual rights.
And I personally respect
religious liberty,
as long as it does not step
on my individual liberty.
I know that some religious
conservatives don't love that,
and there's reasons for that.
But that's the stuff
we have to hash out.
That's worthy of hashing out.
Because the alternative Michael
is at the end of the day,
if we don't do this
thing, they won.
- We get run over.
- They won, it's over,
- congratulations, we're
all in the gulag together.
And then we're gonna really
have to live together
in small cells, and eat gruel,
and it's very cold
and wet in there.
And I don't know that I wanna
be in there with you frankly.
- Well, so since
you bring it up,
you bring up this word sanctity.
You bring up sort of
these religious questions.
You mention we've
gotta hash this out.
Cardinal Manning famously
said, all politics,
all human conflict basically
is theological at the bottom.
One of the more striking
points in your book is,
when we first met
each other, Dave,
when we first became
pals, you were an atheist.
- Yeah.
- Today you are not
exactly an atheist.
- No, I am a believer.
- You're a believer.
- There is no question
about it.
I am willing to
say that Knowles.
Yeah.
- How did it happen?
- Look, there were
a couple of things.
Partly one of the reasons,
I had never, as an adult,
I had never said I was an
atheist until about 2000.
I think it was, if I
remember exactly correctly,
it was the fall of 2015.
So I am now in 2022,
I'm 45-years-old.
So this is about seven years
ago, I'm in my late 30s.
And I always sort of
felt somewhat agnostic,
but I always love
logic and reason.
I grew up reading all
of Carl Sagan's books.
So I loved sort of,
I loved sort of a distant
respect for belief in a way,
but not like a hardcore
belief, something like that.
You know, I also, I come
from a secular Jewish family
that while we did all of
the holidays and traditions,
which is basically what kept
Jews around for 5,000 years,
it's different in terms of,
the belief in God is
a little bit different
than say a Catholic, or-
- We like to say secular
Judaism is Jew-ish.
You know, emphasis on the ish.
- Yeah, and by the way, our
good friend Dennis Prager
has written many
books about this.
That maybe that thing
just can't last that long,
that it's not enough to
like Seinfeld and eat bagels
and all of those
things, although those
are worthy things.
Man, I made an everything
bagel at Locs the other day,
Miami, you can get a,
they say it's all in
New York and Jersey.
I know you're a New
Yorker originally.
- Yes.
- You can get a good
bagel down here in Miami.
But putting that aside-
- Well because where did
the New York Jews go?
They've all fled now, right?
They're all heading down to
the free state of Florida.
- All the sane ones
now are in Florida,
and it's just the bananas
ones still in New York.
But in any essence, in 2015,
I started having a bunch of
well known atheists on my show.
Primarily Sam Harris was
sort of the first one.
And I just sort of started
going into that world.
And for a long time, I
never said I was an atheist,
but a lot of people just kept
saying, Dave's an atheist,
because it was just by the
nature of the conversations
that I was having.
I had Ayaan Hirsi Ali on,
and Pete Bogosian who wrote a
manual for creating atheists.
And Michael Shermer
from "Skeptic Magazine".
I know you know all these guys.
- Yeah.
- And so I just sort of
got in, like sort of
caught up in that thing.
But then eventually I started
saying I was an atheist.
I would say a couple things
started moving me on this.
First off, as you know,
a couple of years later,
I was on tour with
Jordan Peterson
and we did 120 shows
in 20 countries.
And he was not only, I had
read "12 Rules for Life"
and I had flipped through
"Maps of Meaning",
it's a very intense book, but
being on tour with this guy
and every night hearing
a different speech
related to the importance of
belief, and that in many ways,
whether you believe you are
or not, you are a believer.
So I don't mean this to attack
Sam Harris, for example,
but Sam Harris says he's not
a believer, he's an atheist.
But it's like he does believe
that Trump is the devil.
That's where all of his actions
over the last couple of years
politically seem to come from.
I don't really mean that-
- Wow,
he might not believe in God,
but he does believe
in the devil.
That's a great observation.
- I get one, one a show,
that's what I always say.
Then I heard Jordan say a
few things related to belief
specifically that I
really loved, one of them,
you may have heard this.
He was on, this is a
little bit later actually.
So I'm jumping ahead a bit.
But he was on Tucker
Carlson's Fox Nation show,
and he was talking about
the nature of belief.
And he said that when
he was in his early 20s,
he decided to tell the truth
for the sake of
telling the truth.
That in essence, that
if you told the truth,
that that would be the best
outcome, no matter what.
Doesn't mean that it
would be a good outcome,
because obviously you
can tell the truth
and they might hang you for it.
But actually it would
be the best outcome.
That's an incredible
leap of faith.
To believe in truth
for truth's sake,
there's no tangible
reason to believe that.
In many cases there's
the reverse of that,
because we know what happens
to truth tellers, right?
You're gonna be
lambasted, and ask Jesus,
there's a lot of things
that are bad that are
gonna happen, right.
But I really love that
explanation of truth.
That truth for truth's
sake is a leap of faith
in and of itself.
What a great kernel that
is to start with something.
And then through the year of
hearing Jordan talk about this,
and really also it wasn't just
at a personal level for me,
because I do the politics
thing that you do as well.
I talk about things broadly
at a societal level,
and it's like, it's not
working without belief.
Once you remove God, Nietzsche
said, you know, God is dead,
but that's a warning
to you people.
People think, oh God's dead,
let's do whatever
the hell we want.
But it's actually a warning
'cause it's like man,
that hole is big.
That hole is big and
you're gonna fill it
with some other crazy shit.
And congratulations,
now boys are girls,
non-racist are racists,
two plus two is five.
The litany of Latinx
and all the other nonsensical
phrases that we have,
that's what we filled it with.
We filled it with
secularism on steroids.
It's not to say that secularism,
and your ability to live as
you wish, is not important.
Of course it's important.
And I wanna live in a largely
secular society obviously.
But we need some
guardrails on that.
So I would say, some
people's belief is purely,
it's purely spiritual.
They feel a very deep
spiritual sense of belief.
I wouldn't say that's the
primary driver of mine.
I would say it's a
logical, rational,
and almost necessary need
for belief, I would say.
But I certainly feel it more.
Maybe it's a little
bit, I'm 45 now,
so this is definitely what I
suppose they call middle age.
You young whippersnapper!
And so maybe it's a
little bit of that.
Maybe it's also, it
was one of the things
that made me wanna
finally have kids
after not wanting to have
kids for a long time.
There's something going on
here that's beyond us Knowles,
and I think societies
have to understand that.
Otherwise the winds of
the day will blow over
the whole thing every time.
We are in the middle
of it right now.
- It's a similar thing-
- I like you there, I feel
pretty good about that.
- Yeah, no it, I think
you're pretty close to it.
What you're really
close to here is,
is something that so
many people on the left
refuse to get to,
which is humility.
Just saying, there's
something bigger than me.
Maybe I don't have
all the answers.
Maybe I need to suppress
at least some of my
interests and desires,
for the truth for truth's sake.
Similar thing
happened to me with,
I was an atheist for 10 years,
and I was pretty
hardcore about it.
I was pretty firmly atheistic
for most of that time.
And it was only an
intellectual journey.
It was only just reading
and logic and arguments
that took me from,
at least that's how it
appeared to me at the time,
to go from atheist, to
being open to that question.
Now I would say there was
a little more spiritually
going on too.
But it was only
after all of that,
that I started to have
really what you'd call
religious or spiritual feeling.
And as you describe
Dave, the more you do it,
the more you do it, the
more it happens to you,
the more you practice
these kinds of things.
And so it, this raises then
a question for the book,
and we're joking about
what your next book is.
We joke about how
you're gonna end up
to the right of Mussolini,
and all of us are gonna say
Dave, what are you doing,
you gotta come further left.
But a lot of times people
who are on the left,
who then move in more
conservative circles,
they say, I didn't leave
my party, my party left me.
And Bill Maher just came
out and said this again.
And certainly that
happens sometimes.
But it seems to me,
reading your book,
something more than that
has happened to you.
It's not merely yes, the left
has gone completely insane.
Yes, they've moved
very, very far.
But you have changed too.
- Yeah, well,
absolutely I've changed.
There's no doubt about that.
People used to say, oh, your
politics changed so much,
and then I sort
of had that line,
I didn't leave the Democrats,
the Democrats left me.
Or I didn't leave liberalism,
liberalism left me.
But you know, it's funny,
when Bill Maher says that now,
in 2022, it's like that's
what Ronald Reagan said
literally 45 years ago, who
was once a California Democrat,
to ultimately become the
sort of standard bearer
of Republican conservatism.
So this is something Dennis
Prager has talked about
for many years as well.
And even Shapiro's
talked about it.
You know, I got Shapiro once
seven years ago on my show
to admit that in
a perfect world,
he basically is a
classical liberal.
He would never wanna
be described as a
liberal obviously,
and I'm sort of, that was
also a little bit actually
to fully answer your question,
I also became sort of exhausted
by explaining liberalism.
So it, while at
some level I still,
there's nothing that I
wrote in the first book
that I don't believe anymore.
- Yeah.
- For me to run around to
try to explain constantly
how I am a true liberal,
and these lefty whack jobs
who say that they're liberals
are not liberals, and
I have at this point
barely any differences
with conservatives,
the words all become so crazy
that I started giving it up.
But it also was, to
get to your point,
people before me have said this.
Ronald Reagan, I didn't
leave the Democratic Party,
the Democratic Party left me.
So something was going
on a long time ago.
And that does lead to a
little bit of the humility.
David Horowitz is another,
he's like the really
famous example of this,
because he was a lefty, son
of Marxists and communists
his whole life.
Reagan's reelection, he says
he's gonna vote for Reagan.
He was the original why
I left the left guy,
which is a phrase now
associated with me.
But it's like, these things
have happened before.
And it's not just that I had a,
it's not just a political shift.
It is a shift that
is more than that.
It is a shift in some
ways that is spiritual.
And I would say on
the religion thing,
to link it back to that.
Who are the people in the last
two years of COVID insanity
that didn't lose their minds?
Almost everyone on the left
completely lost their mind
at every level.
The very same people
who were screaming
while Trump was president, I'm
not gonna take the vaccine.
I don't trust the government.
All of that stuff.
We've all seen the videos
of all of the MSNBC hosts
and all of the Democrats,
Kamala Harris included.
I don't trust the CDC,
and who are these people,
and Trump should fire Fauci.
The second the politics shifted
and they had their
guy in office,
they were saying the
complete reverse,
and also saying it was gonna
be mandated on you too.
That is somewhat spiritual.
It is somewhat spiritual because
the people who stayed sane,
they weren't making
their decisions based on,
oh, I like Trump,
I don't like Biden,
or I don't like
Biden, I like Trump.
They were making their
decisions based on
the sovereignty of their
mind and their body.
And it's actually
quite irrelevant
who was in charge politically.
So the people who I found
over the last two years
didn't go bananas,
and by the way an awful lot
of people did go bananas,
many of them atheists,
they prove something to me.
The proof is in the pudding.
So when I meet all
of these evangelicals
who the left always
tells me hates me,
and they're nice and warm
and welcoming and happy
and come to my shows and hug
me and say nice things to me,
and then they didn't
go COVID-crazy,
you think that maybe has a
little something to do with
the fact that they
believe in something,
and what they believe
in is not government.
I think maybe there's
something there.
- One of the great
hoaxes during COVID
was that the crazy
right-wing Christians,
they think they could
never die from COVID.
And of course the
opposite was true.
The reason that,
generally speaking,
conservative Christians
remained sane during COVID,
is because we know
we are going to die.
We're not going to
eliminate germs and death
from our society.
We were looking at the numbers.
We're looking at the evidence.
We said, you know, I think
this is being over-exaggerated.
I think this is, I actually
don't think this poses
as great a threat to
me, a healthy young guy,
as we're being told it is.
I don't think the
masks are doing exactly
what we were told
the masks are doing.
I just don't really, I have
faith in the eternal things,
death and taxes.
I have faith in my God.
I do not have
faith in Dr. Fauci.
And it was on the
left that you had
this neurotic fear of death.
This absolutely preposterous,
cultish worship and idolization
of some bureaucrat
in a lab coat.
It's ironic that the
people who are accused
of fairy tales and make
believe, were the most grounded.
They were the most empirical
people the whole time.
- Well, we could even
connect that to something
roughly going on right now,
which is that the very
people who for the last
however many years have told us
how much we should hate
evil corporations, right?
Corporations have too
much power over us,
and they buy too much
political influence
and they must be evil.
And they're somehow
capitalistic.
That's doubly evil.
Who do they love right now?
They love Disney.
They love the most evil
corporation in the world
that is trying, I mean
DeSantis is literally
fighting Disney tooth
and nail right now,
to keep their policies out
of Floridians' classrooms.
He's the guy that was
elected to be executive,
chief executive of the state.
Now you may not
like his policies,
but that's what his job is.
And that's what I
mean about people
flipping all of their
beliefs, based on politics.
And you can't disconnect
that from people
that don't have a belief
in something else.
If you just believe that on any
given day, whatever happens,
whatever happens politically
or culturally, that's reality,
you are going to
be freaking crazy.
Especially in an age of
algorithms, and big tech,
and bots and everything else.
If your world view is this
got a lot of retweets,
that guy said the thing,
and he's wearing the lab
coat and the rest of it,
and the fact that, you know,
and the book does go
quite heavy into this too.
The mainstream
media has lied to us
about absolutely everything.
So now you take
a bunch of people
who maybe don't have a
very strong, original
say base view of the world.
They haven't figured out
if they believe or
they don't believe.
They're not sure if they
believe in individual rights
or what they really believe.
You take them, they're
already sort of shaking.
Now you take a pandemic,
you throw it on top of that.
Now they're really kind
of crazy and scared
and everything else.
And then you take a media
that has literally
lied about everything,
from Hunter Biden, to
Brett Kavanaugh's a racist,
to the Covington kids,
to Kyle Rittenhouse is
a white supremacist,
to very fine people
on both sides,
to the litany, to
Jesse Smollett, we
could do this all day.
- Yeah.
- Well, of course you're
gonna end up with a population
that is half insane.
Or a population that
half of it is insane.
- Right, right!
You bring up your governor
down there in Florida,
and you brought him up
a few times now, Dave.
So I have to ask, we're having
this wonderful religious,
cultural, philosophical
conversation.
I wanna put all that aside.
- And by the way,
you're a great host, I just
wanna say, really great host
- Stop it!
- by the way.
- Come on, get out of here.
- Really fantastic.
- You're gonna make
me blush, come on.
If I weren't so
tanned I'd blush.
But I want to, I wanna
put all that good stuff
aside for a second, and
talk about rough, hard,
nuts and bolts politics,
because this is a
big theme of the book
and what we're
talking about here.
What are you gonna do about it?
You've got this, you got a
right-wing right now that is,
doesn't have very much
holding it together.
And the conservatives are
becoming more conservative
and the libertarians are
becoming more libertarian.
We don't have the old Soviet
Union to hold us together.
The left is getting so
much more aggressive,
they barely see any distinction
between anyone on
the right anyway.
They wanna just kill us
all and salt the earth
on which we once stood.
Is there someone who can
bring us together in 2024 say,
whether that's your governor,
whether that's Trump,
whether that's someone
else in the country.
Is there someone who can do it,
or do we need to wait
for a new candidate?
- Well first, as I try to
make the argument in the book,
politics is not
gonna save us here.
So the stuff that's
gonna save us
is what we started
talking about,
which is the build new things,
figure out your community
and your life and all that.
However, politics
is not nothing.
There is a reason that
we do this for a living.
And even if we want,
even if in the world
that you and I
Michael wanna live in,
politics should be small
enough to fit in a little box
that we can tuck
away in our pocket.
That's not what
we have right now,
so we have to fight
for that, let's say.
And at the end of the day,
the size of that thing may
be a little bit different
for the two of us.
I would say this about DeSantis.
Look, it is not gonna
get better than him.
It really isn't.
In American context of politics,
with a deeply corrupt media,
I would say at this point
an evil corporate press,
you are not gonna get
a better guy than this.
He's 42, 43-years-old,
military background.
He is fearless in
fighting the media.
I've had dinner
with him a few times
and I've spoke to him a couple
of times and I've listened,
I've gone to events
where he's spoken at,
and I can tell you this guy,
he does not wanna be king.
He does not wanna be your ruler.
He's a guy that's sort of,
it doesn't even
sound at some level
like he wants to be president.
Like he really sounds
like a guy that should be,
and I guess this is a little
bit of the Trump thing,
that he should be
running a business.
He's like, I say things,
I make decisions,
we see what happens,
and then I do it again.
He doesn't get
affected by polls.
He's strong, he's
picking the right fights.
And I say all this without,
I don't worship politicians.
Obviously I happen to,
I like and admire
the guy, obviously.
But I like and admire him
because of the reasons that,
because of the fact
that he wants to mostly
stay out of our lives.
The point of the don't say gay
bill H1557, which again has,
the word gay isn't in it,
and they could've just
as easily called it
the don't say straight bill,
because you're not allowed
to talk about straight sex
with a second grader
obviously, you morons.
The point of the bill
was to keep the government
out of these things,
that state employees
shouldn't be discussing
these things with kids.
It's not more government,
it's less government actually.
It's the government reining in
what state employees can do.
So that to me is the type
of thing that we want.
Now we have a great
problem, I would say,
a good problem here in Florida,
which is that he's
up for reelection
obviously in November,
he's gonna win by a landslide.
I think he's, well he's
gonna win and I hope,
and I believe it will
be by a landslide.
And then what I hope
happens from that
is that landslide then
really causes the states
to start going like
dominoes one by, you know.
We got the Youngkin win,
it was pretty damn close.
DeSantis will win by more.
Hopefully Texas stays red.
Tennessee's obviously gonna
stay red, you're gonna be fine.
But then some of the places
that could go either way
are Colorado, Indiana, okay.
That they're gonna fully go red.
And then it doesn't mean that
everyone in those red states
is going to have every perfect
Republican party platform.
I always remind, and I
write about him in the book
in a different context,
but everyone thinks and
knows that Rudy Giuliani
obviously is a conservative.
Rudy Giuliani happens
to be pro-choice,
but no one's doubting
that he's a conservative
and that you would want
Rudy Giuliani on your side,
regardless of the bad hair
dye dripping down his head
and some of the yelling
and everything else.
I mean, he's a good guy, you
would want him on your side.
He's a fighter.
So I want DeSantis
to crush here,
and then I suppose after
crushing here, crushing here,
that then he is the
best candidate for '24.
The Trump thing is
what confuses this.
Would the best situation be
that Trump is the bodyguard,
run the rallies,
fight for the platform and
the party and the country,
and let DeSantis go through?
That's the best situation.
Can Trump do that?
Does he wanna do that?
Does he wanna put his
ego aside to do that?
I'm not sure.
And the other problem
with the Trump thing,
and I look forward to
interviewing him again,
and I hope if you interview him
that you could ask
him this directly,
which is that the fear
with the Trump thing,
I think there's two real
things, which is one,
would the machine
allow him to win.
- Right.
Whatever the machine-
- Would it even
be possible, right?
- Would it even be possible?
That's number one.
And number two, even if you
accept that the machine would,
whatever I mean by that,
the base of the Democrats
is so depressed right now,
their candidate has dementia,
and the backup woman is I
think, has the equivalent,
let's say, IQ of
maybe a sixth grader.
She was polling at
zero in her own party.
Everything is a mess right
now, inflation, gas prices.
They made up the war.
The other thing,
it's all terrible.
But suddenly if Trump runs,
you can probably get five
million extra people to show up
outta the woodwork, just
'cause they hate Trump.
So Trump really has to
acknowledge those things.
And again, that's
not a knock on Trump,
and I really would ask
him that to his face,
what he thinks about that.
But all of that being put aside,
I think there's such
a rich opportunity
for a truly interesting
wide tent Republican Party
right now, but it's gonna
be work for us, man.
It really is.
- I love your point
too about, yeah,
obviously you want a good
presidential candidate.
You hope it could be
this guy or that guy.
But even before that, you
get a big win in Virginia
and then you get a
big win in Florida.
And especially in Florida,
DeSantis has done
a pretty good job
selling the political agenda
of the parental rights
and education bill, of going
after these woke corporations.
And so you're seeing
trickle effects of that
all throughout the
rest of the country.
That's really what we've
gotta focus on right now.
If you can turn the country,
if you can turn the states,
you're really setting the stage
for a much larger national win.
Now we've been talking about-
- Michael, let me just
say one thing real quick,
'cause your own life
is an example of this.
We had that conversation
in my backyard in L.A.
where we said we were
gonna stay and fight,
the next day you
announced you were leaving
and you were moving
to Tennessee.
Okay, fine.
I tried to stay and fight,
it was a fool's effort,
I accept that, it's all good
now, I'm in free Florida,
you're in free Tennessee.
But the point is, don't
you feel in the year plus,
about a year and a half I think
that you've been in Tennessee,
don't you now feel, and this
is the way it's supposed to be,
this is federalism, that
the state that you live in
is actually far more important
than the federal government,
especially when we have
a federal government
as inept as this one.
So that's all good actually.
- I tell my friends
who are in L.A.,
I've still got a lot
of friends in L.A.,
a lot of friends in New York,
I have a lot of friends
in the swamp in DC,
and they were complaining about
the masks in the restaurant,
the vaccine requirements,
and COVID, when
will COVID be over.
And I would tell
them, I'm sorry,
I don't really know what
you're talking about.
I know what you're talking
about because I travel,
and so I have to be in
DC for a night or two,
or New York or wherever.
But in my day-to-day life,
COVID has been over for a year
now, more than a year now.
And so you're totally
right on that.
It's really important to
focus on those states.
Hopefully that
changes the country.
Before we go, the most
interesting thing, one,
the book is very, very funny.
The book represents
this very interesting
kind of evolution
of your thought,
from the first one
to the next one.
I hope there's gonna
be another one.
So beyond just predictions
about the future of the country,
or the future of the
conservative movement,
do you have any predictions,
seeing how your views have
grown from the first book
to the second one, do
you have any inkling,
any intuition of where
you might be headed
in your own thought,
spiritual, cultural, political,
and where that next
book is gonna be?
- Knowles, you're
a fine interviewer.
You're a fine, fine interviewer.
You are.
- Stop it.
- Well I do obviously,
and I think that
that will probably be
what the third book is about.
Although everything being equal,
if the ideas in this
here book take off,
we wouldn't need a third book.
That would be my preference.
It really would be.
We can all talk
about these things,
and then they seemingly
get worse year after year.
The preference would be hey,
we built a whole bunch of new
shit, it's time to move on.
Get the old copy-
- I'll be on my boat.
- Yeah, exactly.
Get the old book.
But I do have some
thoughts on that.
I mean, I'll tell you one
that I've been
thinking a lot about,
at a very personal level,
that is also related to all of
this, which is so, you know,
David and I have been
together for 13 years,
we've been married for 7 1/2
years, something like that.
We're having two kids.
And it was funny because
when I made this
announcement publicly,
I got I would say
99% love, truly.
And this is one of those things
where the internet is very
hard to gauge what's going on,
because my phone's blowing
up, texts, phone calls,
all of the public
people that we all know,
everyone basically
congratulated me
either publicly or privately,
said wonderful things.
There were two or three blue
check people on the right,
in the more religious
circles of the right,
that tweeted some, I thought
somewhat nasty things.
And then you get just like
a whole bunch of
anonymous trolls.
And one of the things that
was interesting about that,
you know what, I won't even
say all anonymous trolls.
You get a lot of
anonymous people,
then you get some
people expressing
some legitimate
religious points,
which I'm happy to
get into if you want,
and then you get
the trolls, okay.
I got a lot of
people saying to me,
I'm so sorry that you
had to deal with this
over the last week.
So much hate in such
a beautiful time.
You're trying to expand your
family and all this stuff.
And it was kind of funny
because I'm used to
the internet game,
like you're used to
the internet game.
And if I was to pay
attention to what trolls
or anonymous people are
saying all day long.
- You'd get nothing done.
- Yeah, that would be it.
I would get nothing done,
and I'd probably be in
a mental institution.
I'd be in a padded cell
just scrolling mentions
on Twitter all day,
which actually is where most
people do their tweeting from.
So it was mostly love,
but it really did,
well wait, first it was
mostly love, but secondly,
people kept saying, you see.
All these people on
the left kept saying
see these people on the
right, they really hate you
you fucking asshole.
Pardon my French, it's my show.
But the reason I
say it that way is
the people who purport to
be the tolerant people,
even in a moment like this,
were being meaner in a way
than the religious people
who sometimes weren't
acting so religiously.
So I got no love, literally no
love from anyone on the left.
No mainstream gay magazine
or MSNBC or whatever said oh,
here's this interesting
political commentator
who wrote this bestselling book.
He's having kids.
That's an interesting
cultural moment.
No, it was endless hate
from them, nothing but hate.
Not one liberal commentator
that you and I both know
messaged me privately
or anything.
But I get all this love
from the conservatives
and then some
trolls come with it.
Anyway, I mention this
because it did make me think
that as we talk about this new
alliance, say on the right,
well, I'm gonna
have a family now.
And what comes with
having a family
is very much what's
in the book you have,
you're an individual,
now you have a community,
then you have a larger
community around you.
Will there be work
that I will have to do,
to show these people
the value of my life,
or what freedom is, or what
pluralism is or something?
You know, when I had Ben Shapiro
on my show the first time,
the first time I ever
had him on the show,
and I don't think we had met,
or we had tweeted
at each other maybe,
I don't think we had met.
And he said this thing about,
that he wouldn't bake me
a cake for my gay wedding.
And it's like, I've had
kosher cakes, they're dry.
Nobody wants kosher cake.
- Nobody wants that cake.
- Yeah, you need some
butter in there or whatever.
They're dry.
What I said to him was,
and I've said this repeatedly
to him over the years,
that my personal belief is that
if I live as a decent
human being on this Earth,
in a good relationship to
the best of my ability,
and I raise decent children
and try to be a good
member of the community,
and all of those things,
which I'll do
completely imperfectly,
as I suspect you
do imperfectly too,
that over time, if Ben
and I interview each other
and do whatever we
do for 50 years,
when I'm 82 and Ben's 77,
that he may, although he
maybe will never say it,
maybe will at an
individual level
have come around and
go man, you know,
that conversation that Dave and
I had 50 some odd years ago,
his life had meaning
and it had value.
It brought something
to this world.
So that's why,
whatever disagreement,
it's not even disagreement,
whatever difference
you and I might have,
theologically let's say,
it doesn't matter
that much to me,
because I think we
all also operate,
we can operate in
the realm of ideas
and then we can operate
in the realm of reality
that is right here.
And I don't think,
as I said before,
I don't think you
wanna just do this one.
You do have to do both.
But I think there's other ways
to show the world what you
are, something like that.
And I think that will
be a bit of my challenge
going forward, really.
And by the way,
it's not just me.
A guy who works with you,
who I think is a fantastic
thinker, Spencer Klavan,
is getting married to Josh
in the next little while.
- Wait, Spencer Klavan's gay?
- That's what I read one summer.
I'm not sure Josh
is, but Spencer is.
Spencer's very, he
lives in Tennessee.
Tennessee is a little more
religious conservative,
let's say, than Miami,
Florida where I am.
Here I am in a fairly
conservative place,
but it's a little
more ethnically mixed.
It's a little more sort of
New York, Republican mixed,
something like that.
So a guy like Spencer is
gonna have a real challenge
in those things.
But that's what life's about.
So that alliance that we
were talking about before,
it's not just an idea.
It's not just an
alliance of ideas for me.
It's actually an alliance of,
I'm gonna have to put my
best foot forward in that.
I'm gonna have to
live in that thing.
And by the way,
even if it does not work out
exactly as I hope it will,
and the future's not written,
I know it's better
than the other thing,
because I will not live, I
will not live on my knees
as just, as a slave
to a bunch of people
who think they own me
because of an immutable
characteristic.
I just simply won't do it.
- It's funny, I guess
it's not really funny,
but when you mention
the announcement,
not only did your Twitter
blow up, my Twitter blew up.
And a lot of people wanted
me to publicly condemn you.
And I said listen, if I'm
gonna condemn my friends,
I'm gonna condemn my
friends privately, darn it!
I'm not gonna condemn
them publicly.
If I'm gonna go after Shapiro
or you or whoever else.
And I think in part, this
is because on Twitter,
everyone is just a box, right.
On Twitter, everyone.
It's quite clear, I've made
no secret of my Catholicism.
Catholic church is clear,
not just about homosexuality,
but surrogacy generally,
IVF for married couples.
It's clear, you're
pretty limited
to the things that you
can do in the boudoir,
and I think Norm McDonald-
- But the irony, sorry,
but the irony of that, without
getting too deep on this,
is that, the Catholic
church itself
has made fairly egregious
errors, to put it lightly,
related to some of those things.
- In practice.
- That's actually,
that's not even me, that's just
sort of a factual statement.
The point being that we all
live between a set of beliefs
and a set of reality,
something like that.
- Yeah, yeah.
And even in that case, there's
a line from La Rochefoucauld,
which I always come back to,
which is hypocrisy is the
tribute vice pays to virtue.
You know, this idea that
when people screw up,
but they're, not if
you're living as a liar
or as a cynic, so it's not
really overt hypocrisy,
but when people screw
up, when they sin,
when they error, that
is a human thing to do.
And so there is this idea
of holding a standard
that you are going to fail
to uphold a lot of the time.
I was so curious when I
saw all these people say,
I want you to come out and
publicly condemn your friend.
And I thought, why, what is
the purpose of all of this?
I don't think I really have
quite an answer for that.
I could, I have an answer if
someone were mealy-mouthed
or didn't know what they
believed, but frankly,
all of our beliefs
grow over time too.
I mean, there is a world,
when I say you could
end up to the right
of Genghis Khan or something,
I'm only half kidding.
You could end up in a position
where your views on
the nature of sex,
I'm not saying you're gonna
like not be gay or something,
but where even your views
on that could be different.
And we all confront that.
I mean, when I think
about my own behavior,
when I think about my own life,
my views have
changed considerably.
And so when you're
talking about a coalition,
the first part of
having a coalition is
having some loyalty to one
another, having some kind of,
recognizing that your
friend is different
than the guy who's trying
to kill you and your friend.
- Michael, well it's very easy.
If we wanna find
enemies all day long,
there is no shortage of enemies.
We will find them every
time we open up our phone.
We'll find them every time
we walk out of our house.
We'll find them every
time we turn on the TV.
So actually I got,
my Twitter was so outta
control those couple of days
that honestly, I don't think
you condemned me publicly,
and I appreciate
you for doing that.
- I don't do that.
I also thought I said,
wait, you want me to be,
you want me to stand up
and be a big strong guy
by piling onto my
friend publicly?
And what's the point of that?
That makes me a big strong guy?
No that makes me a coward,
that makes me a weakling.
- But, you know, because the
other piece of this is how,
and this very much
is in the book
related to the big tech stuff,
is that the algorithms
and the way we all behave
has been so supercharged and
dysregulating for all of us.
So think about this.
Let's make it about
another topic altogether.
Let's just say you and
I were doing a show
and we were debating
tequila versus bourbon.
- Scotch.
- Scotch, okay.
I'm still a little
unclear on the difference
between bourbon and scotch.
Do you wanna clean that
up for me real quick?
- Absolutely, yes.
I mean, I could do
it intellectually,
but it's better to have a taste.
- Okay.
So let's say we did a video
and I think we've done,
we did this for the game
show on your channel once.
I love tequila, you love scotch.
Okay, great.
And every time we're together,
I have tequila, you have scotch.
Now we can do that video, and
we could agree to disagree
and have a ball and be
plastered by the end,
and let's say that video
got a million views,
and 900,000 people
just don't comment.
They just don't comment
'cause they're like oh,
I watched it, Rubin
likes tequila,
Knowles likes Scotch,
zippy-damn-dooda,
I'm going to buy coffee.
What happens now is you've got
a hundred thousand
people that comment,
and out of those
hundred thousand people,
the type of people,
I mean we know this,
the psychological makeup
of the people that comment
is going to be more drawn
towards the negative,
and then the comments
that are the most negative
are gonna be the ones
that get the most likes.
So then if you then,
now a week passes,
it's got a million views.
It's got let's say a
hundred thousand comments.
90,000 of those comments
are completely terrible.
I like tequila because I'm gay,
you like scotch because you're
a heterosexual supremacist,
blah blah blah.
- A super straight.
- All of these awful things.
And then the average person,
then just the average person
happens to click on the video
and before they even
watch what we're doing,
they look at the comment section
and all they see is hate.
All they see is
the endless hate.
And that I think relates back
to exactly what
we're talking about.
The average person that
exists on planet Earth,
especially in the United
States of America,
is just trying to make
some sense of this thing.
And just trying to do in a way
that is hopefully somewhat
decent and allows you
to listen to some music you like
and eat some food you like,
and hopefully be with
some people you love.
That's it.
But the internet has, and I
mean dysregulated is the word.
- This is a great point.
- It has completely skewed
our ability to see reality
for what it is.
So my reality, again, on
that day, to link it back,
was oh I'm getting all this
love, my phone's blowing up.
I don't pay that much
attention to the mentions.
And then suddenly
a few hours go by
and I see friends texting me say
I'm sorry you're dealing
with all the hate.
I'm going what hate.
- What hate, yeah?
- So that's one of those
things, but Knowles,
I do know that while we may
disagree on tequila and scotch,
we do agree on Frankie Valli.
- Well, we do agree on Frankie
Valli, among other things.
One of the all-time greats.
Great way to facilitate, while
you're drinking and chatting.
And actually, speaking of
one of our drinking buddies,
Spencer Klavan, he made this
point, he made it to me once,
the same point that
you're making right now,
which is so much of our
political rancor right now
is just trying to come to
grips with the internet.
Is just trying to come to grips
with this explosion
of technology
in the way that we can all
be manipulated with that.
It reminds me, you were talking
about that bill in Florida,
the parental rights
and education bill.
The vast majority of people
don't think kindergartners
should be taught about sex
in history class.
Well, they don't have history
class, in alphabet class.
- I'm pretty sure
in history class
they don't learn about
history, so it's okay
when they're a little older.
- You make a good point.
But the vast majority of
Americans don't think that.
The chasm between the vast
majority of ordinary people
and the thin sort of
bipartisan ruling elite,
but it's obviously on the left,
but there's some Republicans
who go along with it,
who control all of those
institutions, it's huge,
and they are inundating
us with this idea
that it's somehow controversial
not to teach kids about
sex in kindergarten.
I just, I love your
sort of saying, hold on,
pull yourself out of
Twitter for a second.
You talk about, and this,
we're running outta time
so we'll have to wrap it.
You have to buy the book and
just read about it yourself.
- Great book, great book.
- But you talk about, when
you go on your sabbatical,
you go on for 30 days,
you don't pay attention
to anything anymore.
And then I've hosted your
shows, so when you've come back
and you say what happened, I
threw my phone in the ocean
for 30 days.
That is rejuvenating.
It is important to
remember that there is,
there is a real society
we're living in,
with real people who
actually generally do
kind of agree on things,
and do kind of broadly have
this idea that there's truth
and falsehood, and
we kind of know it.
And not to get completely
lost and manipulated
by a small handful of bad actors
with a ton of political power,
that we all, in the sane
kind of center to right,
are unifying to try
to push back against.
- Knowles, wouldn't
that be a dystopia?
Wouldn't that be a dystopia
that we all sort of roughly,
not all of us, but like there's
this real majority of people
that roughly understand the
mess of the gestalt of life,
and that we can't quite
see it because the AI,
the algorithms Skynet turned on,
the machine wants more clicks,
and it can get more
clicks off more clicks.
And that we're all
playing this game
that none of us
really understand,
but we all kind
of know it's fixed
and we don't know how much
it leaks out into reality.
But what that all leads
to, and I will tease this,
you're the guest
host of my show,
but one thing that I have
not said publicly before
but I wanna drop
some first time info
on "The Rubin Report",
my goal, and I hope
I can stick to this,
I wanna close my Twitter
on January 1st of 2023.
- Really?
- I have over
a million followers.
I have wasted a lot
of my life on there.
But it's also been
very good for me.
But there is something about
the Twitter game in particular
that I think is
really breaking people
in a really weird way.
I think I've roughly
managed to stay sane in it,
but I think if enough
of us just say enough.
You know, Tucker Carlson right
now is banned from Twitter,
and has been banned from
Twitter for a couple weeks.
Nobody's talking about it.
The number one host in
the history of cable news
is not allowed to be on
Twitter because he said,
in essence, that men have
penises and women have vaginas,
and he's not allowed
to be on Twitter.
On top of the Hunter
Biden laptop story
and everything else.
So what are we doing?
We're giving energy to something
that is trying to destroy us.
We're feeding the plant in
"Little Shop of Horrors",
then it's eating our
friends and we're going hey,
why you doing that?
I did a little bit-
- We're tweeting about it.
It was pretty close.
Yeah, but I do love that idea,
we say Twitter is the devil,
it's the worst thing ever,
it's completely destroying
our country, hold on,
I've just gotta finish my tweet.
Just tweet, tweet, tweet,
tweet, tweet, tweet.
Of course, you're putting
your time, your energy.
That's actually, that
is a big deal Dave.
If you go off of
Twitter, it reminds me,
you talk about it in the
book, of going off of Patreon.
I mean, that was a big deal,
you took a big financial hit,
and then you didn't,
and then you prospered.
And so I hope the same thing
can be true on Twitter.
And for all of us, as
we build a new culture,
build new institutions
and we buy this book.
"Don't Burn This Country,
Surviving and Thriving
in our Woke Dystopia".
Dave thank you so much for
coming on "The Rubin Report",
I really appreciate it.
We're gonna have to
have you back sometime.
- Knowles, I'm sending
you a bottle of tequila.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.